the newly passed coveted relief package
is facing new uncertainty this morning
because
of president trump he said last night
that congress should triple the size of
direct payments to families
or he might not sign the bill his list
of demands surprised both parties
president was largely absent during
months of negotiations the president
also announced a series of controversial
pardons sparking accusations
that he is abusing his power chip reid
is at the white house covering all of
these developments chip good morning
well good morning last night the
president suddenly demanded
that that amount for the stimulus
payment per person be increased from six
hundred dollars
to two thousand dollars that's been the
democrats position
all along so they seized on the
opportunity by scheduling a vote for
tomorrow
raising that amount to two thousand
dollars
it really is a disgrace in a surprise
move
president trump last night demanded that
congress revise
the 900 billion dollar covid relief
legislation
that was passed just days ago i'm asking
congress to amend this bill and increase
the
ridiculously low six hundred dollars
to two thousand dollars or four thousand
dollars
for a couple it was republicans not
democrats who were mostly opposed
to higher stimulus payments house
speaker nancy pelosi tweeted last night
at last the president has agreed to two
thousand dollars democrats are ready to
bring this to the floor this week
by unanimous consent the president also
railed against what he said were
unrelated provisions in the legislation
505 million dollars to belize costa rica
el salvador guatemala
honduras nicaragua and panama most of
those provisions were in a separate
government funding bill passed
jointly with the kovid relief
legislation the president's announcement
was met with concerns from both sides of
the aisle
republican senator lindsey graham
tweeted the kovid 19 package while
imperfect will save jobs and lives
while democrat mark werner asked does
the president realize that unemployment
benefits expire
the day after christmas we won by a
landslide
the president also released a second
video last night in which he railed
against the election results and brought
up unfounded claims of fraud
both of the president's videos were
posted just minutes after the white
house announced a controversial wave of
pardons
among them george papadopoulos a trump
2016
campaign adviser who was convicted of
lying to authorities
as part of an investigation into russian
election interference and
alex vanderzwaan a lawyer also convicted
of lying during the russia probe
people who lied to cover up for
themselves or for the president
they get a pardon you know it's just
another
body blow against the rule of law in
this country the president also granted
clemency to three
former republican congressmen duncan
hunter chris collins and steve stockman
all of whom were convicted of separate
financial crimes
he is trying to burn the house of
justice down on his way out the door
the president also pardoned four former
security guards with the infamous
security firm
blackwater they were convicted in
connection with the deaths of iraqi
civilians in 2007. now all these pardons
are already fueling more criticism
that the president is abusing his power
by one count
88 percent of the people the president
has given a pardon to have a personal
or political connection to him